plus cartonne vraiment moi j'ai cherché
coûte quoi toi je coûte le wat tadjou
jul après big flo et oli j'ai oublié
après j'ai oublié dit raymonde m
maignien ok merci à tous cas des princes
1 1 sans escale est supra noah qui
revient avec un nouvel arrêté c'est bon
et je suis pas charlie et lulu marois on
est en train de parler on a vu le le
héros il ya un instant le héros de
l'avion et je vous avais demandé ce que
vous avez déjà sauvé des vies with les
parties vous avez peut-être servat trice
lama très bien ne se rencontrent que le
gars est parti alors alors vous mathieu
de rioux avait sauvé une vie oui moi tu
as déjà sauvé une victoire ou un truc
sauver une vie je sûr qu'à l'école si je
regarde tes clips et ou sur quelle école
tu tombes rouille et toi t'as fait quoi
et à quel âge moisan 22 ans et arrêté
l'école à quel âge j'ai arrêté en
première donc je ne sais plus assez en
dépendent arrêté en même temps mais je
suis sûr que tu t'embrouille à l'école
les deux dernières années ah ouais
j'étais sûr je vois dans ses clips et
toi mais tu as joué je vois qu'elle est
non dans un délire et me déjà fait un
bien arrêtez moi arrêtez d'en rire est
comme un mixage faut pas mettre les
questions suivantes
prenez les jams et moi alors j'ai une
question pour marois alors moi c'est
quand la dernière fois qu un coup de
coeur pour un mec aulas a jamais
réellement eu un coup de coeur pour un
mec à la fin au jambon et co gérant john
ont encore à l'émission n'est pas
terminée je pense que j'ai encore le
temps et ton style au total neuf soirées
qui par israël
je me suis à table
[Musique]
car les attend ils sont cinquante ans
au soir ou jamais fait humoriste la
vérité kenny vous kiffez marois j'ai
quelque chose à dire ma peau de kelly
non pas pour vous de marwa j'ai vu que
kelly elle a fait un tweet le 27 juillet
si je me trompe pas elle a dit ah oui
elle est la posture
tu as posté khellil lala l'album voilà
juste une personne peut comprendre ça et
je vais demander si c'était elle et sur
un maillage pour qui en fait l'album
cheveux ou la croix 4,8 n'importe quoi
elle a kiffé la chanson assez lydia
jebet en libye et c'est tout et en plus
je suis elle a dit c'est pas maxime guy
maxime pénible soutien on va on va mener
l'enquêté
c'est une très bonne émission par contre
j'ai pas la cible parce que j'ai pu huit
ans je suis pas mère de famille mais par
contre j'aime beaucoup l'émission sont
les tlc et il faut le dire c'est quand
même l'une des rares émissions du paf
qui progresse par rapport à l'année
passée assez fou et c'est à dire que
cette année est la dominion 7 alors que
la nuit l'été dernier c'est à 2 millions
6 et ça faut quand même le sol de plus
en ce moment c'est incroyable mois yoann
vous tapez pas oui non elle elle dort
merci mais non
matthieu delormeau ah oui j'ai bâti ma
fille match suis pas comme un ouf sur
l'émission honnêtement me quand je tombe
dessus je regarde la tangente un avis ah
ouais enfin paraître je réponds oui
tiens minéraux de serre nous c'est
marland c'est marouane non c'est pas toi
tu étais partez pas comme une ruf
je suis pas trop fan mais en fait on va
toujours le même genre de l'épreuve qui
porte tu vois noms des participants
ouais donc y arriver à voir tu vas
lacrymo bonne gouvernance on doit
reserrer son équipe mais je t'écris est
sûre faisait ça la progression est pas
où